تواجد الان في جباليا البلد بعد ارتكاب
الاحتلال مجزره هنا بعد تدميره لعدد من
المنازل وهي ماهوله بالسكان مما ادى لوقوع
عدد كبير من الشهداء والاصابات وما زال
ايضا بعض المفقودين هنا الدمار كبير جدا
في هذا المكان حي سكني بالكامل دمر في هذه
المنطقه بعد قصف الاحتلال لهذه المنازل
طبعا هنا المنازل متلاصقه ببعضها البعض في
هذه المنطقه في شارع غزه القديم في جبالي
البلد طبعا كما نشاهد حجم هذا الدمار الذي
طال هذه المنازل والمنازل المجاوره تحت
ركام هذه المنازل هناك مئات الشهداء ما
زالوا تحت الركام لم تتمكن الطواقم الطبيه
او الدفاع المدني من الوصول اليهم لا
يتوفر اي امكانيات هنا في هذه المنطقه من
اجل انتشال الشهداء من تحت ركام هذا
المنزل الاهالي يحاولون الوصول لعدد كبير
من الاطفال لم يتمكنوا حتى هذه اللحظه
بسبب عدم توفر الامكانيات اللازمه للوصول
لهؤلاء الاطفال نشاهد هذه الصور المؤلمه
هنا بعد قصف الاحتلال لعدد من المنازل هنا
في جبالي
البلد حسبي الله انتشال طفل من تحت الركام
هنا في هذه المنطقه لف
لفط هذا يحيى
معنا الان الناجي الوحيد من هذه المجزره
بعدما فقد اكثر من 60 شخص من عائلته من
عائله علوان هنا في جباليا البلد ليحدثنا
عن ما حصل وعن هذه المجزره الذي ارتكبها
الاحتلال بحق عائلته هنا في البيت فليله
ما ننقش في البيت سمعت صورت الضربه اللي
انا لقيت كل اهلي ودار عمي كلهم مستش جدين
كلهم اطفال كلهم رضع كلهم ابرياء فش فيه
واحد له في التنظيمات كلهم رضع وابرياء
كلهم اطفال مثل الورد كلهم نساء مثل الورد
لسه الشد صهيون المتجبر قام بقصف الاطفال
دون سابق انذار وهذا الاحتلال المجرم سوف
يندم هذه هذه مجزره هذه ناس امنين ناس
مبعدين وقاعدين عند الجماعه هذول عند
جماعتهم هذه الدار تحتوي تقريبا دتين
ثلاثه تحتوي على 100 نفر
على 100 نفر وما فوق وفيهم اصابات كثير لا
حضار ولا تنذ ولا انظار ولا اتصال ولا شيء
هذه هذه حكومه فاشله هذه حكومه تش ما لقتش
اهداف ما لقت اهداف للمقاومه صارت تدك
المواطنين الابرياء كل اللي ماتوا هون كل
اللي ماتوا كل اللي ماتوا هون اطفال كل
اللي ماتوا هون اطفال هذا حرام عليهم هذا
هذا الدول العربيه اللي بدها هيك وهذا
امريكا اللي بدها هيك ونتنياهو فاشل
وحكومته ساقطه
باذن الله باذن الله مهما ينزل علينا
صامدين وصابرين ومتحدين ناس قاعدين حي
بالكامل جماعه بدهم ياكلوا جماعه بحطوا
اكل قاعدين بدهم يطعموا اطفالهم لانه ما
فيش لا قوت ولا اكل ولا شرب ولا خبز ولا
شي في البلد ودبروا لادهم طول اليوم مي
واكل وشرب حي كامل نزلت اجت طيران نزل
عليهم ثلاث براميل مش صواريخ ثلاث براميل
هد علم حي كامل حي كامل واحنا بطلع
الجماعه بارك الله فيهم كل ه الجماعه هول
بلعوا في شهدا وبزيل من تحت الركام ومش
قادرين مش قادرين يطيعوا اكثر من هيك اطلع
ايش اطلع ايش بسو تحت السقف اطلع الشهداء
اطلع الشهيد ايش هذا هذا هذا ضرب هذا ضرب
هذا ضرب على اسرائيل هذا ضرب على اسرائيل
صواريخ هذه بنت ضربت على اسرائيل صواريخ
الحكومه الفاشله حكومه الهاش عندك 76 يوم
واحنا تحت الحصار وتحت الضرب تحت الضرب
هذا وبطلوا يفرقوا بين مدن وبين مقاومه
بارك الله ف المقاومه بتصدم وتتحداه من كل
جحور ومن كل الاراض ومن كل المناطق وهو
بلاقيه شدف بلط على المست على المواطنين
بفكر انه يمحي اسم غزه لا احنا راجعين
وراجعين وراجعين لارض ال 48 وراجعين للقدس
ابا من ابا وشاء من شاء هذا تقريبا دار
300 متر فيها اربع مخازن كل مخزن في كلب و
مش اقل من 30 40 واحد مخليين يعني في في
معه من السجل المدني صاحب الدار هذه له
تسع بنات والتس متجوزات بجزان باولاده
بنات المتجوزات كلهم انطو تحت المبنى هذا
ما ظل عننا حاجه نخسرها بعد هيك ماظل ويظل
يعطي يظل يبعث واحنا بنعطي وعنا شهداء كفي
نتنيا وحكومه نتنيا قديش
بده من وسط هذا الدمار الذي خلفته طائرات
الاحتلال بعد قصفها لحي سكني بالكامل هنا
في جباليا البلد مما ادى لوقوع عشرات
الشهداء ومازال هناك كثير من المفقودين
تحت الركام انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه